I reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey over at our patreon yes I'm
going to repeat this we do weekly Q&A as
well as TV show reaction watch along for
many of things and a few times a week
John does music video coverage
transition we are going to cover BTS not
today official MV music video I have no
idea who these guys are
today's requests one of our top reward
tiers whatever video your requests we
must definitely do it put up on the
youtubes it hopes especially when it's
music that doesn't get blocked worldwide
let's find out so we're probably gonna
have to cut this one up just so it can
at least be visible probably not
monetized but visible for YouTube's
today comes from Natalie Doran who is
raving so much about these guys that I
was like alright let's finally do it
you're taking the world by storm we
ought to 271 million views gosh
they probably made like $100 off this
video
Oh easily maybe even 150
it's a dollar every million views see
what all the hypes about yo yo V yeah
every kpop video I've ever seen is like
massive production value
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
see why this musics addicting yes oh hey
crow tits I always wondered other
translations shows where the boy bands
Linda huh
chica leveled up yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you ain't gonna die today people know
perseverance music wow nice right there
damn
so looks like
[Music]
Oh No
okay to just like awesome haha not
familiar okay Bob
it's the line crow tits
I wonder there's a music video director
is man quite visceral
[Music]
Oh buddy dude that was awesome
yeah right they don't mess around that
was legit awesome it's funny cuz this
has been taking kind of the world in the
Western world especially by storm and I
just keep wondering like this just
sounds so state-of-the-art I'm like are
we stealing people from them are they
stealing people from us and I've heard
the BTS at least do a lot of their own
stuff so god they're all hot yeah well
they've all been working at this since
they were like 12 years anime these guys
seem like they must be one of the most
disciplined groups I've ever seen people
in the music industry in general always
kind of terrify me because I'm like man
you sacrifice so much of your personal
life to become successful in places like
Korea where it is more at least in this
genre of music where it's like alright
we are going to mold you and sculpt you
and you are going to work at this most
days from when you're like 12 up until
the point where you blow up yeah because
man they can dance they can sing and I
like the song I think that song was
really cool yeah that music is like
thank God for the subtitles you know
some of it's in English but it does have
that kind of epic warrior we're gonna
handle this how many ninjas are coming
our way we're going to beat them if you
wanted to feed ninjas I'm part of a kpop
band yeah sing it that's how way you
beat ninjas it's all about respect man
kpop yeah that's the thing as these
songs always make me wish that I
understood the language because there is
just something that gets lost in these
subtitles make sense rotate still it
hurts it makes perfect sense you know
while you keep talking to the camera I'm
gonna look up that that is the correct
crow kids is the correct pronunciation I
gotta believe it though you know John
show them your music video coverage
review stuff come on start reviewing
well I'm looking for this I mean I
thought this was a pretty fun and
enjoyable song for John shut up it's
crow tits it says right here hey crow
tits everyone hands up that's my new
saying right there too and so people
yolk rotates
oh god I love this what does that mean
ever heard it makes sense don't you like
pointy like crow beaks or is this
supposed to be like you know the way
tits might appear if it Reds well while
you talk to the camera and give you a
review I'm gonna look up what crow tits
are on Google Images so you keep talking
to the camera I mean there there are
birds that are actually called tits
little Bush tits and stuff okay yeah
that's what they are that's what they
are a krob tits it's a kind of crow kind
of as like there's crazy framerate
shudders there are like late every step
of this price in all the k-pop videos
I've seen up until this point it is like
this machine that produces these really
high production value really sleekly
shot really laser accurate choreographed
videos like it's just top of the line
and the song to go with it is bad so
yeah also kinetic and gripping and just
you know fun to listen to because it's
produced but it's not produced to death
so it's still enjoyable and yeah and in
the pop world in the US I you know I
have my big guilty pleasure who I'm
setting aside guilty pleasure I love her
Britney Spears I love her yeah but the
boy bands have always been like
something just so corny and cheesy I've
even known a couple of guys who were in
boy bands I hear they're like they're
cool guys but I hate their music
but this one I heard it I'm like man
this is badass this is like actually bad
you know what it is it scrote it's it's
good you know the way in which like when
you watch an anime the dub is different
from the subtitles I feel like we need a
dub like cuz the dub translation always
sounds more natural look John look
Korean croton a type of burb is also has
the meaning of trihard Udo Kareem sand
as a phrase in Korean and that is Korean
which means if AK wrote it walks like a
stork it will break it's like mmm the
meaning is that you'll ruin yourself if
you try to imitate someone better than
you that's that's the message just be
yourself
we're sticking together and they're not
gonna get us cuz we're gonna be our
they'll be ourselves we can be we have
figured it out yeah I can't call someone
CRO tits unless they're just trying to
be someone else yeah don't be a protest
yeah man you know if well don't be a be
a crow tip but just be a crow Ted maybe
if you see somebody just being
themselves then you can say like hey
you're a crow tip man you're not trying
to be a stork or nothin as per this one
specific example I write are Google's
dude that was badass thanks so much
Natalie for introduced now he's telling
us something kind of weird that she
doesn't listen to music or doesn't like
music do not make music binge watching
this and obsessing over it as of the day
we are filming this you were out
partying right now getting drunk
flashing your croquettes are doing a
great job this little bit of man have
you awesome in Ireland oh yeah they a
today taking over the yeah crow chest
rotates over here don't try to walk like
a stork you break you lie then there's a
bunch of [ __ ] ninjas coming after us
right now what is fascinating the way
boy bands have also changed cuz this
isn't what I associate with like
American boy bands where it's mostly
like ballads and harmonies and stuff
this is like they're singing but there's
also like rapping and really heavy beats
and you know electronic elements and
stuff like it's just taking like all the
modes I feel like they're melding all
the most top line popular things into
one super genre yes open Gangnam style
alright guys well thanks for watching
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell
hopefully this video is up on YouTube
and check us on patreon TV show
reactions q and A's the camera caps and
the John does music video reactions look
like comment and the video was like what
is John always look like he's offended
when which video I remember that's my
like whoa what's happening sometimes I
do that kind of like that face but we're
done